[Music]
one thing that struck me the moment I
arrived over them is that the city is
alive with Legion
I wanted to master authentic Cuban salsa
so I sought out the help of an excellent
local salsa man this is Jorge and your
band is Moncada No
is that right yeah I would like to learn
to play the authentic Cuban salsa do you
think that's possible I think so is
there a trick to the rhythm is there a
secret to the rhythm of the salsa
musically no the most important in South
scene and a most of cue music is what we
call Chloe Chloe Chloe on the case clown
is using Chloe these ladies is a basic
rhythm pattern that goes like this here
yeah when girls in Cuba are walking they
seem like being dancing it's like being
with that climate you see yeah that's
real so you spent a lot of time watching
strange women walking in the park that's
what you're saying you see the cloud
everywhere don't you see the Clavijo the
women of birds have the claw they you
dogs with
mama
[Music]
[Applause]
that's the pattern of salsa that's a
little bit but I got to work on my time
[Applause]
no I'm not doing it did I get in there
at all did I do it yeah what if you
didn't know me what if you had no idea
who I was
yeah and I walked up on the street and I
said I want to be in your band and I
played you the club a as I just played
it would you hire me or would you say no
first I will try we will start walking
working and we will get it okay that was
the gentlest no is fantastic you are an
artist well your club a and also on
[ __ ] tell them do you want me in the
band to be honest
this is an honest man you are honest you
just ask yes if I were to sing salsa
what would I see you're getting a kill
how do I sing what sound should I get
you have to think that you are thinking
with the nose see who knows like this I
don't know the words but I'm gonna just
say
[Music]
[Music]
like that
[Applause]
what are you gonna do he's here what do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
arigato
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
did anyone get that down
what'd you think of those lyrics do you
like it
I love that guy